هذه المره تحديدا المنطقه الواقعه بين
جباليه وتل الزعتر وصلتنا الان هذه الصور
عن اشتباكات عنيفه كما تبينها هذه الصور
التي وردتنا قبل قليل الاشتباكات في هذه
المنطقه الواقعه بين جباليه وتل الزعتر
ونشاهد في الصور هذه المقذوفات وكذلك
اصوات اشتباكات
لنستمع
الان اصوات
اشتباكات في منطقه معسكر جباليا في محيط
معسكر
جباليه كما تشاهدون هذه
اليران كما تشاهدون اطلاق
هذه بشكل
مفش
شو
[موسيقى]
اسمه
الان اصوات
اشتباكات لمعرفه اكثر تفاصيل عن هذه
الاشتباكات نذهب الى مستشفى الشفاء في
شمال غزه معنا من هناك مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل هل من تفاصيل اكثر
عن هذه الاشتباكات كما ذكرنا في مناطق هي
بين جباليه وتل الزعتر
اسماعيل نعم بعد تراجع قوات الاحتلال من
كثير من المحاور في منطقه شبال شمال غزه
حاولت التقدم في منطقه الواقعه ما بين تل
الزعتر ومنطقه مخيم جباليه وهذه المنطقه
تسمى منطقه السكه او منطقه الاداره
المدنيه وهذه المنطقه تعتبر من المناطق
الشرقيه ذات الخاصره الرخوه والتي لا
تتواجد بها اي بنايات سكنيه وهي المطله
على منطقه مخيم جباليا والمناطق الرئيسيه
في مخيم جباليا والمناطق الشماليه تحاول
قوات الاحتلال للدخول من هذه المنطقه لكن
يبدو انها تواجه مواجهات ضاريه منذ صباح
هذا اليوم وهناك عدد من الانفجارات واطلاق
الرشاشات سمعت وفق المصادر والزملاء
المتواجدين في منطقه جبالي هذه المنطقه
التي لا تزال قوات الاحتلال تحاول الدخول
اليها منذ ايام وبسط السيطره على مختلف
المناطق في داخلها اعلنت قوات الاحتلال
لانها انهت العمليه في تلك المنطقه لكن
يبدو ان النتائج غير ما اعلن او مخالفه
لما اعلنه الاحتلال
انه يتقدم في هذه المنطقه ويفسد سيطرته
على هذه المنطقه لكن بالانتقال الى منطقه
مدينه غزه ايضا منطقه حي الشجاعيه هذه
المنطقه التي تواجه ايضا مواجهات ضاريه
واصبحت مسرحا للعمليات ولا تزال
المقاومه يعني تضرب قوات الاحتلال بكل
قوتها ونرى ذلك في تزايد اعداد الاصابات
واعداد القتلى من صفوف قوات الاحتلال
تحاول التقدم قوات الاحتلال من هذه
المنطقه الى منطقه حي التفاح والدرج لكن
يبدو انها تفشل منذ ما يزيد عن 12 يوما
وتثبت في محور حي الشجاعيه الذي لا يزال
التي الذي لا تزال المقاومه تضرب من داخله
قوات الاحتلال